the tunnels entrance is located on an
artificial island Martin heron connected
is here to see how construction is
progressing he soon finds himself 50
meters below sea level
work on this section in the South China
Sea is almost complete the tunnel will
connect Hong Kong Airport with the New
Territories most of the work is done by
a tunnel boring machine it's the largest
machine of its kind in the world it has
a diameter of seventeen point six meters
and we used it for the first 1.2
kilometers it's fascinating when you
think that we're drilling a road tunnel
then we downsize to 14 meter diameter
machines have to create an artificial
island to assemble the machine on the
machine weighs almost 3,000 tonnes
that's gigantic the construction project
would not have been possible without her
and connects tunnel driller engineer
spent two years developing it for
Germany is only supplying the parts the
project itself is a chinese french joint
venture the potential for complications
is enormous men risk we have for the
weather from the weather except the
flooding risk is is also transportation
because our he fabricated segments come
all from China 1600 kilometers away and
if the sea is rough or there is a
typhoon the boats cannot come several
lanes of traffic will run through these
shafts and tunnels costing 1.8 billion
euros it's one of the largest
infrastructure projects currently
underway in Hong Kong alongside a metro
system extension with a population of
more than seven million and the island
British Traditions Hong Kong is an ideal
base to do business with southern China
there are a few market restrictions and
everyone has a right to invest there
things are not so welcoming on the
mainland though we're German companies
are primarily in demand as suppliers or
joint venture partners China is known to
keep tighter control over projects a
source of annoyance for German companies
in early November the asia-pacific
conference of German business met in
Hong Kong more than a thousand
executives and representatives of small
and mid-sized businesses were there
Germany's economics Minister supports
their calls for better market access
calling for a level playing field for
years to negotiate on the same level and
deal with each other as equals but we
still face restrictions when it comes to
permits in many regions German companies
are only allowed to hold a minority
stake or were forced into joint ventures
we don't want Martin Herron connect
isn't having any problems with his
Chinese venture his main focus is on
doing a good job precision is everything
to run the machines very accurately to
get to the right location down to the
last millimeter the Machine emerged last
week and returning it around for the
next cross-cut these are the
technologies we're working with here the
entrepreneur is certain no other company
has the ability to make these machines
as a trained engineer he knows what to
look for and appreciate this project
relies on international cooperation such
machines and the techniques were using
it we have you know we have to do it
together right at the beginning of the
project good morning good in good shape
everybody just hoping to continue
working on tunnels in the future
projects are huge undertakings
multi-level tunnels could be a
particular challenge they can go down
build let's say combination Street
Tunnel which will be underneath the
combination insist i meter 18 meter he
also could have three line Rotana
and underneath a metro so we will go
more in multi-purpose tunnel
this is sewerage telecommunication
internet all indicated Martin Harris
knows his company needs to keep
innovating to stay competitive he's
hoping to build many tunnels in China
and says he's happy to team up with
other partners to get the job done
you